okay
okay good evening everybody
um and we're not in our usual spot but
we're very cozy in here this evening and
welcome to Karen and Jill who are
joining us virtually and welcome to Ruth
oh I don't know if you've been before or
certainly not for a while so welcome
um we're not the scary look can assure
you
um
can I ask first
um does anybody know of any apologies
I've got councilor white
um councilor Acton and councilor Whitton
let's see
Council wetton has also sent his
apologies okay
okay are there any Declarations of
interest in any item on the agenda okay
now we haven't got the minutes and so
we're postponing those till the next
meeting if that's okay with everybody
um obviously this is a meeting that
we've squeezed in because of the one
that was postponed in November so
everything's been a bit rushed
um not aware of any
hello any questions from the public
um
so I'm going to go into item five of the
agenda
um and I'm going to hand over to Ruth um
we have had the paper in advance so if
you could just give us a quick overview
and a quick run through you wouldn't
mind
do you want me to go through my slides
just a couple of minutes I've got some
slides just a couple of minutes would be
great yeah can you make it
okay I'm plugged in plugged in and then
you just need to um
I think it's uh FN and then the screen
headphone
[Music]
don't worry I can just talk if you want
uh yeah
I'll just talk that's fine I'll um use
my slides to remind me so I'm Ruth
O'Keefe I'm the head of traffic music
service and I'm the
um advisor for music for Trafford local
Authority as well
um the music service is a much bigger
team then you might remember it being
we've got
um six senior managers that all
part-time apart from one and we have 74
contracted members of staff that are
teachers now that work in our schools
and at our music center and we have a
resource coordinator that's responsible
for all of our instruments
um and we have an admin team of about
five people
um our current delivery and we deliver
something called wider opportunities in
schools these are whole class projects
where we take 30 trumpets into a class
and we teach the whole class to play
trumpet for a term and we deliver those
in 53 of our 64 mainstream primary
schools and this year we'll be
delivering to 188 classes approximately
5 640 children will engage in one of
those projects this year and we deliver
PPA which is a planning preparation and
assessment time for schools and we
deliver to 13 schools currently eight of
which we deliver all the way from
reception to year six and we have
currently
um
45 schools that we deliver instrumental
tuition so like one-to-one lessons and
group lessons and we're currently
delivering to 80 853 children every week
for those those lessons that are in
schools and that's just
the primary schools
um and
we have a music center that runs every
night Monday to Friday at the Claremont
center from uh four till half past eight
every night and on a Saturday morning we
have 521 students that have instrumental
lessons there
um and we have ensembles so we have
um orchestras bands all kinds of
different groups that children can come
and play in so the idea is that they
learn either in school or with private
tutors or at the center and then they
come and play in some of our ensembles
and all the children right the way from
age four through to 18 that play in our
ensembles including our infants perform
at the Stella Hall
um or the rncm every term so we have
concerts at the end of each term so that
they have the experience of playing in a
professional concert venue and and we
were hit quite hard the same right the
gray across
um the country in terms of our Ensemble
numbers by covid so they dropped
significantly at after covid and we've
been working on building those up so
last after covid we were on 235 children
we've increased by 162 children that
come to the Center for ensembles every
week to 397 and that's a massive area
that we're really targeting for
significant growth over the next 12
months that's where we're targeting lots
of our efforts to try and get more
children engaged in our ensembles and
our ensembles have got a really good
cross-section of children from right the
way across the borough from Old Trafford
right the way through Partington and
um alteringham and hail uh so the
perception is that most of the children
come from sale and lots do come from
sale but we have a really good
cross-section we've got some bespoke
infant provision Matt's aimed at getting
children engaged in key stage one so
that we carve out some time for music
for those children
um because they're so busy by the time
they get to key stage two and we've got
really rigorous training programs for
our teachers and to make sure that we've
got the highest quality of provision
being delivered in our schools under our
music center
um and
um other stuff that's within my remix so
I meet with every head teacher every
head of Music Department every year talk
about their music provision look at
their curriculum look at how we can
support and enhance their provision as a
music service and then we do lots of
additional things like big concerts from
singing festivals that engage lots and
lots of schools and we've got a specific
program for shortage instruments
happening this year and really targeting
those instruments that that aren't taken
cannot buy many children and we've
called it Trafford Young Musicians
program and that targets bassoon oboe
double bass French horn those shortage
instruments and we've got 26 children on
that program this year and that's in
partnership with Cheatham School of
Music
um and we're currently
um rolling out a year six transition
project to
have the children have something that
every child in Trafford they'll know two
songs and a piece of music and they'll
they'll do that in their first week
within their secondary school so that
there's some point of commonality
between
a child no matter which school they've
gone to in their very first week in our
secondary heads of Department have
agreed and to take part in that so that
should be something really positive for
our children and that's the music
service in a nutshell
thank you yeah
um so most of most of this is aimed at
infant children do you find that the the
children that have engaged in this in
infants are the ones that are more
likely to carry on throughout the
teenage years so we have the reason we
launched the infant program
um was about 114 children have got the
exact figure somewhere that are in the
infant program the reason for that is
because
Trafford children are so busy in year
three and from year three upwards
because there's so much on offer so we
wanted to make sure there was a time in
the week that they could do music and we
have about a 98 retention into year
three of those children
um however most of our primary schools
we start tuition in key stage two
um so they don't offer instrumental
lessons in school most of them I'd say
probably 80 of primary schools offer it
from key stage two so lots of children
do start their journey in key stage two
we do have a fall off into key stage
three and four and that's because of the
grammar school system because
traditionally grammar schools have their
own provision so we're the main provider
for all of our secondary non-grammar
schools but most of our grammar schools
with the exception of Stratford and sale
grammar have their own provision so
their own private teachers so because
it's convenient for parents lots of our
children will go from primary school
into that second into a grammar school
and then move to them but we tend to try
and retain them for our ensembles
anybody else
um
at Council Hornby I'm one of the
councils for God's Hill award I wanted
to say just how great is that we have
this as a borrower and have it in-house
at the council as well because it's such
a special provision isn't it to be able
to offer that to our children and and
that every child can benefit I just
wanted to ask um do we have a good
coverage of program in the deprived area
of Trafford and kind of what does that
look like across the borough
um and what can we do to enable more
children in the deprived
world-specifically to to take up
learning instruments so yeah we have
really good coverage nearly all of our
schools have our wider opportunities
program and that's free
um for parents so there's no charge
um for for children and so nearly so the
ghost Hill is an example I think all of
the all of the schools in
um stretford and Old Trafford have the
wider opportunities program so those
children are learning for a minimum of a
term and then I work with head teachers
to look at how
um and that's why I have those meetings
each year to look at what we can put in
place for those children who want to
continue but for whom Finance is a
barrier so many head teachers will use
their people premium funding and to
support instrumental lessons in school
and we offer so we have a bursary scheme
that runs alongside the music service
it's like a parent's Association but not
a parent so Association like a PTA for
the music service and they do
fundraising at concerts and things doing
Raffles Etc and that that means that we
can fund bursary places for children
either whose financial position has
changed and so they've been a member and
then financial position of change and we
can continue with their lessons all with
their ensembles or for whom just they
just want to have provision so the
schools take care of the the work in
schools they but we have a separate kind
of
um way of funding children that want to
come to the Center for lessons
um
councilor Bennett
some years ago it was so damned about
being able to remain at the Clermont
centers
um I don't know that everything's
resolved but what I do know is that the
proposed move to Stratford is as not
going forward and so
um the the last bit of information that
I was given was that we would be um
remaining in the Claremont center
um in the short term while they look
alternatives
I'm still black then
thank you and my apologies for being
late
um could I just ask about the funding of
residentials
um
so
um our residentials that we run are
funded by parents and so they
um we build a full cost analysis of what
it costs to go away including paying um
our staff
so the staff don't get paid anywhere
near the number of hours that they're
actually on the residential and then we
recharge that to to parents and it's
fully costed so it's everything is
covered there's no cost to the council
at all for those residentials
um and we have the offer of the bursary
scheme as well for any children that
would like to come but for whom finances
um a barrier so for the last residential
in Preston we
um funded two children 50 and two
children 100 percent
it was your latter remarks that I was
particularly interested in so thank you
[Music]
uh I'll declare I'm sorry for being late
as well um declare a huge interest in in
this issue uh because my children have
gone through the music service
um are currently in the orchestras and
the Jazz Band there and you know I have
to say I hold the service in
hugely high regard
um and uh yeah they're enjoying the uh
the trips that you're putting on now as
well looking forward to going to France
in the in the summer so it's it's great
that you're expanding out into those
kind of things particularly after you
know the constraints of covid you know
really going for it
um I was noticing in the documents that
you're you're talking about the
Claremont center for coming over
oversubscribed
um and you're looking at using other
sites and I was wondering if those sites
are likely to be you know away from sale
and that Center you know are you going
to be looking at urmston or you know
kind of other or Partington or anywhere
kind of as to put up a sort of a
satellite type at the moment it's not
something that we're looking at in terms
of satellite provision in terms of
expanding the the first thing that I
think is being looked at is the
possibility of um creating two rooms out
of one room at the Claremont center to
give us provision for an additional
teacher every night and on a Saturday
which will give us
maybe I don't know 30 extra hours of
tuition
um
I don't know that there's that there's
any looking into any any satellite and I
think it was mentioned a few months ago
that that might be something that the
challenge with the satellite
um a satellite Music Center is that
while we're based at sale
um we have a big staff in infrastructure
in terms of safeguarding so we always
have a member of Staff that's on the
door to sign children in and out we have
our admin team that are there to deal
with parental queries and we have a
manager on site to to lock up at the end
of the evening and make sure the
building's secure and to run any um if
there's a fire Etc we would need to
replicate all of that stuff so it would
have to be a really quite substantial
satellite to cover the costs because we
have to cover our costs so I don't know
that that's being locked into but it
would certainly be something that would
need to be fully costed before before it
was possible
thank you I also need to declare I
didn't realize so you uh were you
working with the children's school for
music I'm just School governor for
school music so that I I need to declare
that uh Second my question is really to
understand if we have any uh Anthony
minority children sign into this music
Services if you do that do we have any
Ratio or any number we can try to sort
of understand how many of them yeah we
have significant numbers of children
that um a non-white British
um because we draw children in from all
over the borough
um for example I can tell you we've got
in the region of 10 children that have
started within the last 18 months who
are humped from Hong Kong who have
relocated to Trafford and that's just a
number off the top of my head I could
certainly get some further information
on exact breakdowns for you if that
would be helpful and then I can feed
that back thank you
foreign
for coming and thank you to members for
questions
um it's great to see the services
thriving
um
you're more than welcome to stay but if
you've got somewhere you'd rather be
thank you Valentine's Day my husband
will be making something lovely tonight
yeah if only but thanks again
yeah we've got a huge a big concert
series on the 26th of March where we'll
be for 400 500 children performing
across the day and and we always send
out the the invitations to all
counselors so you are more than welcome
to come and see
um all the children performing that for
a bit that'll be at the Stella Hall
to be
okay
um so I'm going to move on to
um item six the offsted inspection
outcome and I'm going to hand over to
I don't know if it's going to be chill
or counselor Hines is it Jill yeah
[Music]
thank you for joining us
suggestions
[Laughter]
[Music]
plot the agenda items around so that our
information
that would be profitable and it can that
be helpful to you
no problem thanks
and to talk you through the information
that's available thank you
thanks Jillian Jill and I had a
conversation just before actually
um
a counselor Weston about how we'd run
run this with me not actually gaining
the Readiness as Jill said there were
lots of contributors to the report and
so we did cover off early years so we
Sweeney uh uh put in some information
around that now so he's on legal
unfortunately so if there are any
questions I'll take those away if
there's anything I can't answer around
early years and obviously we try to
bring in finance colleagues as well to
support but Julia's going to kick things
off and then I'll come in after that
that's all right thanks German
thanks Jill and Karen uh for that
introduction good evening
um everyone so um I'll take the report
as read and just pull off a few key
headlines and then obviously uh attempt
to answer any questions that you have
I suppose
um you'll all be really familiar with
the bigger picture you know the rising
cost of living and what won't surprise
you is that that is happening not only a
greater impact on our poorer communities
than our more affluent communities but
also that it's having a bigger impact on
households with children than the
general population and we know that
there's also that north-south divide of
the child poverty rates are higher in in
the north
um and what I've tried to include for
you is some of the more local data from
the greater Manchester residence survey
because that's been undertaken quite
recently
um I think the last iteration of that
was in uh November and so we could see
that nearly 60 percent of households in
GM now reporting food insecurity at some
point in the last year and when I say
now you know that's probably higher now
um I'm looking forward
um I suppose as we go into the spring
people won't need the heating on as much
but other costs will continue
um to rise and the cap on energy costs
will come up and come up in April so
um
that impact obviously affects families
in different ways
um and there is uh certain ways that we
can really support them locally even
though many of these economic drivers
are National and indeed um even Global
um you know there are some unclaimed
benefits where we can really encourage
families
um to take up what they're entitled to
some of the examples there the Healthy
Start to benefit
um only 72 percent that are eligible are
claiming that and we've got Healthy
Start tasks for in Trafford working to
try and improve that uptake
um the other thing about that is we know
for example that those
um benefits no longer cover the costs of
some essential
um staples such as infant formula which
uh you know the cost of a a packet is
now above the value of the weekly
benefit and that obviously presents a
risk in terms of infant health and and a
knock-on anxiety of course for families
who may feel that you know they can't
afford
um to to
um feed their
um family a healthy diet
um and and likewise free School meals
um but we do have quite good uptake but
there's still
excuse me a bit chesty
um still 14 of those eligible uh not
taken up that
um a benefit as well
um we know that
um as a result of these increased
pressures people are needing to borrow
more rely more on credit
um at finding
um Heating and other energy costs
um and affordable and again that's
impacting more on certain households and
you've got a breakdown there you can see
the parents of children in the early
years
um in particular
um 68 uh having difficulty affording uh
energy costs one of the ways that we're
responding to that in Trafford is the
establishment of the living rooms
project
um and that's really been successful and
we know that um there are currently 58
living rooms operational across the
borough and 54 of those welcome families
and children now we're not actually
tracking who goes to those because we
want to make it as very kind of
accessible as possible
um so we don't want to be taking
people's names when they come so we
don't have figures in terms of how many
children and family families
um are attending but we have I've had
anecdotal feedback
and and we know that families are using
those spaces particularly when there are
activities going on
um you know maybe
um there are films showing or there's a
games area
um and where possible including
provision of information and advice
increasing the amount of benefits and
Welfare advice that is available in some
of those spaces
um and even the war rooms that are
situated in
um in buildings that would normally
attract an older age group we're hearing
that grandparents are bringing their
grandchildren along
um and they've got toys and games
provided so I think that's been really
positive
um response and that has been taken up
and we've clearly got our poverty
strategy
in in Trafford now and that's based
around a cash first response so that
really provides more dignity for
families and there's been an agreement
to provide additional payment
to directly employed staff to uplift to
the real living wage including Council
staff primarily on low pay bans and
eligible School staff as well so that
kind of gives you the the broader
picture and then if I can I'll pass over
to Karen who'll talk a bit more about
the impact on early years and
educational settings
thanks Jenna
companies and whether it's around energy
bills and so on and so forth and as a
result of that and there are various
um uh sort of support packages that were
in play through all the education
settings which again has been detailed
in the report both at a national level
and then what we're trying to do um
within brother as well so again I won't
go through that too much because that
was all detailed for you
in terms of the schools yes schools have
continued to experience some significant
increases
but also I would say as well I think
Julia alluded to it before and just the
increases in Pay Awards particularly for
the lowest funded members of Staff
within schools which absolutely is the
right thing to do and and and schools
has certainly wanted to make sure they
they support and reward rewards after
but I think in real terms they're not
necessarily have sufficient finances or
budget increases
um to actually mitigate some of those
additional costs so we are seeing some
increasing budgetary pressures and we'll
stay as particularly in the special
schools and again largely because they
will have
um a larger volume of the lower loaded
Workforce with the the higher rates of
teaching of systems and support
assistance but also because of the
complexity of needs within their
children and young people they've got
all of that additional equipment which
again and it incurs additional costs
around
um
electricity etc etc so we all haven't
really watch what's happening with the
special school funding
finally we wanted to report about the
the household support fund that we get
and you can see there you know we had a
significant sun coming in of 1.45 a
million and it's very clear about from
the guidance about what that's targeting
out and it's absolutely around
supporting our households in the boat's
need particularly those who may not be
able to get support from elsewhere and
and Louise Shaw who
um sort of supports with that whether
through traffic assist and so on and
share some of the detail with me
actually today about the last quarter we
have to report a quarterly spend just to
evidence that we're using it in the
right way and it's been really positive
um to see where the funding is actually
gone so over the course we get about 773
000 the majority of that has gone to
households with children we've actually
held five and a half thousand households
which is it's just a fabulous way
and obviously we also support households
with pensioners and with disabled people
as well
and the vast majority of that funding
then
um has been allocated around the free
School Meal support in the holidays so
where we've issued vouchers and but also
an energy and water costs as well with
energy and water we've helped about 2
200 families as well
um which which is just great work as
well as food and Everson support or food
support excluding the the Amsterdam
vouchers
and majority of that funding and against
you are alluded to foreign
[Music]
we can take some questions now if I'll
be out of course does anybody have any
questions Council home
hey councilor Hornby
um I just wanted to ask what can we do
as a council and as counselors to
encourage the parents of the 14 of
children eligible for free School meals
who do don't claim it and also the 28 of
people and the families that are
eligible for the Healthy Start vouchers
who are not taking those because they
are quite significant numbers aren't
they
I mean I can pick up the preschool meal
bits if you want to I don't know if you
want to mention anything around healthy
stuff but certainly I have the
information service and that is part of
their work their Outreach support to
make sure where families are eligible
they can even support with the actual
application process so
um that's certainly something that our
family information service do do try and
help with
um schools as well and early years
providers I think are key in this and I
think sometimes what's happened is when
we had the universal preschool meals or
the infant children for our key stage
one children I think that's possibly
where we saw a bit of the drop off
really and so schools found all sorts of
ways of trying to make sure that
families understood one that they could
still apply for additional support and
but also to to come and take the stigma
out of it so certainly when when new
children will come into their nurses or
into their schools they really made sure
there was a targeted appropriate all the
families to just chat you know are you
eligible help us help you know let us
help you with with the application
process so I think through the schools
providers themselves and the from the
information service we continue to push
through that that piece of work there's
an eligibility Checker as well that we
can have the families with to see that
they actually know what they need to be
to have to be able I was going to say
just as a sub point it's the same thing
really but do we have any of the data
about who's eligible and who's not
getting it because I know we've found it
really difficult in the pension credits
campaign and we didn't really have data
of who it actually was that wasn't
claiming in obviously that does make it
quite difficult to target the people if
you don't know who they are doesn't
there
I think we do Link in with other
agencies and other providers and if I'm
right to I think do we Link in with I
think we look at
um I think it's traffic assists that can
help identify those families that aren't
that are eligible for aren't applying
because they'll draw information in from
from different uh service areas but I
mean I've got something I can take
awareness you've got the information on
natural
I think that's right but I think we'll
um just confirm and and get back to you
and just in terms of the Healthy Start
benefit
um I do know that that nationally has
recently changed it's no longer a
voucher it's now
um again less stigmatizing and I think
that in itself has increased uptake
which is really positive but in terms of
local specific actions
um I've just recently picked up this
agenda of children's last week so I
don't have that level of detail now but
I do know that um we've got this group
that is focusing on that so I'll find
out what their key actions are if it's
okay I'll report that back to you
because I'm sure we'd all love to help
promote it as well
appreciate your support with that thank
you I think at the moment we've got
families and that are struggling and
facing hardship perhaps for the first
time that have never been in this
situation and they don't know the ropes
they don't know the system and if you've
never had to claim anything before
how how are we sign posting it
um and you know to make it clear that
there is no Stigma um
you know I mean I'm talking people where
perhaps both parents are working but
they're still struggling to pay a
mortgage or rent and put food on the
table
um everybody's in that position aren't
they it's heat or eaten
unfortunately it's the youngsters that
are going to be adversely affected in
the long term
I mean we certainly share the advice on
the council website so it's on the
directory as well so and you know we can
certainly stand post parents there but
you know that's something I can take
back to the family information service
most certainly Council western and you
know just making sure we do that
Outreach as best we can absolutely
just to say that that's something which
The Hub managers the community hubs have
fed back to our cost of living group
that they are seeing a different cohort
of families coming forward who have not
had this level of need before and don't
understand the way the system works and
so they're doing some specific targeted
comms and engagement work to reach out
to those families that haven't needed
the hubs before
um and uh to offer that support and sign
posting around navigating an unfamiliar
system thank you so I've got councilor
Blackburn councilor Maitland and then
councilor Proctor
thank you um with regard to the uh the
drop in the number of child minders
um and it's it's mentioned that
traditionally it's been an older
demographic is there any indication that
um that the there are there's an
increase in unregistered child mind is
in the borough or are more grandparents
taking on the role this is why I was
late today I did 10 hours with with my
two so this is this is why I was late
but um is there any indication that
there are there's an increase in
unregistered ones
no not no not what I'm aware of uh
certainly when we have
um
when we have what we actually haven't
turned in meetings we don't stand around
early years as well and providers and we
have the conversation around
registration and unregistered etc etc so
um we're not aware of of that it's
certainly something I can tape out to
see you know what the mechanisms are to
check around that I think you point
around grandparents and and just parents
working in different ways I think that
is is absolutely contributed to this dip
so for simsco big families and we've got
used to working from home or working
different hours or flexible etc etc so
the fact that just find different ways
to manage their children and I do think
that that is an absolutely a big factor
[Music]
I think is the conversation
um Illustrated I'm probably going to do
a bit more work in terms of
interrogating the data and seeing what
we can understand about what that guy
Gap is
different strategies for different
people so if it's for example
um parents carers that have never needed
to rely on the system having them
navigate
might be about information sharing might
be about giving some of our communities
and some God Parents carers I think the
the question about is the rule we can do
with elective members who know our
communities who can get into some of the
places that we might be able to get into
is is really very funny also I think
it's about people standing as much as we
can about all those gaps in in uptake is
really because I think we will need a
targeted approach and a different
strategy dependence on on who the
cohorts really is but I'm not sure we're
at that level of sophistication yet in
terms of the data something that's
definitely more for us to take away
intensive conversation about
um registers and unregistered I don't
know councilman whether you saw some of
the national research that actually said
oh mighty good stuff some of the
grandparents and school of
relatives or other things today actually
this is getting a bit much hoping out
and some of the things that parents
talked about since there's a lot of
impact of of Cove is more flexible
lifestyle from what that looked like I
think
certainly it was the national report
that was saying that might be the
ready-made sorts of child care at the
moment so again it's a really
interesting government for us to to look
at and try and get a bit further thank
you
so Maitland
I I just want to go back to the Healthy
Start and
um
uh free School meals have we got
physical
um literature and leaflets that we can
promote this with
I think it's not all about being online
is it and it it we've got to have
something there so the voluntary sector
if they can be included in promoting
um this as well you stay and play groups
you you play groups and another thing
about uh going back to grandparents is
the grandparents benefits for the child
care have we got enough information
about that
um available as well
I haven't got that but again I can
certainly request and see if we can get
back to you on that absolutely yeah most
certainly
I think in terms of the leaflets and and
you know something more physical around
eligibility and that that would be the
work of the funny information you go out
into the communities and do do Outreach
I think there's certainly opportunities
where we get family or soft and ground
as well you know you've got a kind of
effect mechanism then in to get to
really promote
um you know that eligibility to most
certainly
so I've got councilor Proctor councilor
Hines and then councilor Duncan and
councilor Wilson
thank you so my question is about child
minders
so too many years ago to remember I
worked for a charity funded by Trafford
called Trafford under fives that was
there to support child minders play
groups and private day nurseries
and we were involved in the recruitment
process for child minders because there
is always turn over but looking at these
figures there's been a huge drop in the
number of available child minders
are we involved in supporting the
national Child Learning Association in
recruiting new child minders
or if there's a there should still be
traffic charmanders Association it just
concerns me that it's
60. we've lost 60 child minders in a
relatively short amount of time thank
you yeah I think that would have to say
I think it's you know it's
a hold we're not We're Not Unusual you
know this is happening all over the
country we're not an outlier in terms of
this position and I think it is a
combination as a say of the Fallout of
covid of their kids business continuity
sometimes people literally cannot afford
to to manage their business and for them
to do what what was done before
um and as I say I think as well you know
and I since had a child blinders go on
to find other jobs because you know it's
more profitable for them and
particularly in the best of cost of
living but obviously is having to pay
for all of our utility bills themselves
whilst they've got these children at
home too so I think it's a very very
complex picture I don't think there's an
easy answer to any of this but what I
would say is it is it's absolutely going
on all over all over the country and
what it was saying is you know we have
been impacted in terms of our
sufficiency and our ability to actually
offer child care support to our children
families we're actually one of the
highest nationally so you know whilst we
have seen that production the positive
think is traffic remains very very
strong in actually delivering on that
sufficiency
[Music]
thank you chair and thank you Karen
Angela for the report I think my
question may well be a follow-on from
councilor Proctor's question actually so
I'm not sure if you'll be able to
necessarily answer it
um I think you mentioned Karen that um
there is a decrease in
students graduating with the skill set
and qualifications to go into the sector
um and I wondered what we are doing
around
promoting the sector working with
Trafford college and our schools
um in this area and if there is more
that we can actually do to bring people
through into uh into this area of work
thank you
I think it says you just said it's
linking in with traffic College
um where we can identify that Gap in
terms of the workforce and skills that
um so absolutely the team the team are
working around that and I think one of
the one of the other positive things we
uh Bright Futures education trust which
is our teaching school club in in
Trafford
um and it's actually across it's across
motor GM actually and that's based at
Ultraman Girls Grammar and we have been
granted funding for what's called a
stronger Hub which is around early years
provision and I think actually although
at the moment the work is very much
targeted at supporting and training the
workforce in the current Workforce if
you like in ppis child minders as well
as
schools as well and I think there could
be a really really good mechanism this
is funding attached to our piece of work
to actually see who we can again and do
some more around Workforce Development
linking unit students coming through the
sector most definitely so I think
there's opportunities there and as well
as like specific work around traffic
college and some of our athletic
partners
Jill did you want to come in with your
hand up for was it a legacy
just job nuts and Workforce developments
and Lincoln with schools and travelers
College there's been some work on going
in an adult social care around
supporting schools to offer Health and
Social care options as part of their
curriculum and
um through the work as the practice
Improvement and learning service in
addition to parents and service area
sailing kids in with the quick release
on the adult side to see how we can join
initially those opportunities
whereabouts premium people into the
cares sector in terms of the range of
opportunities from an adult perspective
for the principle applies on the
children's side as well so we're
actually looking at what we can do and
what moving we can take from adults in
terms of that
thank you um councilor Duncan didn't
have a question yeah
yeah thank you very much I'd just like
to go back to the free School meals if
that's okay
um where it just goes on to the figure
of 789 not taking up the benefit of free
School meals
I'd just like to know or if I've missed
it please
um who's actually got to that figure of
789 and could we actually write to those
families could the council work with all
all Partners to ensure these funders are
made aware of I don't know whether
people touched on it I don't know
whether that's that's possible please
because some of this got to that figure
we must be able to talk
yeah and I think that will have come
through traffic assist actually so most
definitely we can you know we can take
that away and and certainly see if we
can do a much more targeted approach
most definitely okay thank you thank you
to the Wilson
[Music]
thanks chair um
obviously uh energy costs are affecting
institutions throughout the um
throughout the education system I know
that councilor Brotherton is working
with Springfield Primary School
um regarding a community energy project
it's a greater Manchester Community
Renewables
um and I know several other schools are
interested in that scheme which requires
them to lease out their roof space for
20 years
um to this community Energy Group and in
return for which they get 25 percent I
believe off their energy bills or at
least electricity bills
um I'm just wondering oh you know if
you've been part if you've been hearing
about this and what you know what are
the chances are of the council Council
owned roof space in schools being let
out but also is this an appropriate
thing to point our you know our Nursery
sector two you know a lot of a lot of
nurseries have quite large roof space
maybe you haven't had the money to
invest in solar themselves but it's a
way for them to go for solar and reduce
their energy bills at the same time and
you know is it appropriate for the
council to to put that kind of offer to
them thank you
in the first point yes I know a lot of
our schools that have heard of that so
these schools in the South and as well I
think I think they've
received you know the helpful
correspondence around that I think in
the first instance there's a few
concerns that we won't necessarily see
The Return of the 25 for a while so I
think we're just having to to kind of
factor factor that into their thinking
um but I think certainly as as things
evolve I think more and more schools
will be we'll be looking for those
positive opportunities I think in
setting the report that schools have
been eligible for some additional
funding and from government and there's
any small amount a nominal fee but it's
actually around trying to you know make
those modifications and investments in
trying to reduce the overall cost for
schools and but I think your point about
rolling it out Across The Early Air
sectors are you know it's a really
helpful one and it is made we only have
two local Authority day nurseries
currently work Authority so obviously
organizers are privately owned but it's
certainly and it's delivering their own
houses and there could be all sorts of
different buildings couldn't they but
it's certainly something that we could
run out as part of the
um the the advice that we are offering
to schools sorry to settings every year
settings
thanks Karen councilor C thank you my
question very similar to Mike's is carry
on these similar issues around the uh
how the school to to respond the energy
cost increase uh I noticed on the report
you mentioned there are additional
School capital fundings for 22-23
financial years and also you mentioned
when the function we allocate they must
do some capital projects so my question
is does school do those capital projects
on their own or Council coordinate all
those Investments because that may have
different impacts and also we want to
make sure the money can be spent
efficiently announced effectively I have
the kind of can achieve the the best
results
yeah and it was quite difficult to to
hear some of that but I think in terms
of the funding that you were talking
about
um that schools are eligible for for
those
um internal adjustments schools will be
responsible for the decision making
around how how they spend that funding
and and how best they can you know get
those savings back back into their
school and obviously Governors are
they're the ones that hold that hold the
hands to account they're responsible for
the budgeting of that and certainly
where possible you know if our faculty
will help schools with some of that
certainly working with other with other
agencies and contractors to help bring
about some of those modifications if
that is the case and some of our schools
obviously that are
um volunteerated or academies and
employees it's a different route in
there and and they will have other other
partners that will be responsible for
making any modifications and adjustments
to the building things but and it's
schools ultimately that will be
responsible for the decision making
around spend in the first place
depending upon their own their own
buildings
I'm not sure whether I answered the
question there because it was quite hard
to hear I think your answers the
questions but I also they created even
bigger problems I think because that
yeah as I say the school doesn't have
any uh capability to make decisions how
do you invest how to do those capital
projects without professional support
how can they ensure the money can be
spent in the right way yeah yeah I see
what you mean yeah I mean they they
absolutely will reach out to you know
the capital team to to support with that
most definitely but and I mean you're
you're good for yourself you you know
you'll know that there will be uh
government on the board who are
responsible for overseeing some of the
capital work that goes that goes on in
schools and and that's predicated on all
sorts of information that Governors will
hold about the buildings and their
schools but the the local Authority does
have a small Capital Service that will
provide advice and support when
necessary
thank you
thank you thank you Karen for um the
report and thank you to Jilla
um first time joining us um I'm sure it
won't be the last
um and could I also um ask you to thank
Zoe and Marie as well for their input to
the report thank you to members
um thank you you're more than welcome to
stay with us
um both of you but I'm sure you've uh
far better places to be so I hope you're
soon feeling uh better anyway Karen
thanks very much
so
um we go on to
um the ofsted inspection outcome so
we've got
um Jill
um virtually we've got Pamela here and
we've got
um Council behind sue the exec member
for children's so it's going to start us
off
go on then I'll let you know
five ways of quick introduction
obviously we've done a brief slide down
to pull out a few highlights but to
focus as well on some of the areas but
we still feel we have more to do we've
deliberately kept the slides at short
because we know all the defense but one
of the things that you would probably
want to do was to have an in-depth
discussion and I know from some of the
comments at the time that the inspection
report was published the key interested
you as a group of members took in terms
of the recalls so it doesn't propose to
spend too much time going through the
slides panel drawers and really
pertinent bits and what we'd like to do
is really just open it up for all of
your questions and comments and you know
that we can talk for a leave link on it
but we wanted to make this as useful as
possible okay
my name is Jill I'll hand over to you
okay thank you I think the first the
first thing that we wanted to pull out
really was that this was quite different
to the 2019 short inspection
um at that time Trafford we were judged
to be good and so we had a much reduced
inspection visit and that was two days
this was the full ilac which was three
week
um three weeks in duration one week I
sat in two weeks on site and the range
and depth that was uh considered in that
town was significant and significantly
different to the previous inspection and
so just wanted to to kind of clarify
some of that really and talking to a
range of practitioners managers iros
conference chairs Foster carers young
people teachers the whole range from
early help to adoption
um so it it's fair to say that we felt
that and and rightly saw because you
know we we wanted them to test out our
self-assessment that we felt we were no
longer in that place where we were
inadequate still lots to do
um and they agreed with our
self-assessment which which was really
reassuring
they they highlighted as you as you see
in the letter the judgments um are all
that requires Improvement to be good
um in 2019 people will remember the
impact of leaders on social work was
inadequate which meant the overall
effectiveness was was inadequate
um and I think it's probably
relevant as well that that the practice
at that time in 2019 was very close to
the inadequate the conversations that we
had within spectacles subsequently there
was a consideration of whether some of
the practice issues
um were inadequate at that time as well
but they've noted significant
improvements
um in in all the areas I won't go
through all of them because you've
obviously will have read the letter and
have had some conversations you yourself
but I think the culture change the
visibility and accessibility of leaders
and managers alongside that corporate
and political support that children's
social care and early help have had come
out very strongly in terms of the um the
overall summary
the the help and protection uh the
experiences of children who need help
and protection
some really
um positive uh comments there around our
first response service our timeliness
our oversight and that had been a
significant issue in 2019 so that huge
partnership strengthening our
safeguarding referrals Etc but there are
some some areas there still um that we
we need to focus on and I'll come on to
that that shortly in terms of homeless
young people EDT and our pre-proceedings
processes
similarly lots of strengths are
identified in in cared for children and
that covers across fostering Services
adoption
um cared for children and care
experience young people as well
um one of the significant issues there
which we've talked quite a bit about at
corporate parenting board I think was
one of the themes a couple of months ago
is is the impact of changes of worker
for for children and that and impinging
on that relationship development with
children and people their families and
and our carers as well and
some some further work to do absolutely
in terms of the consistency of our offer
to some of our care leavers particularly
those in custody
um there was some feedback around
um our support to care leavers who were
parents as well which is an area that
didn't come out as a as a recommendation
and but was fed back so Jill and I had a
daily keeping in touch meeting for an
hour with the inspectors so there was a
richness of feedback that was coming
every day much of which didn't make it
into the letter because it would have
been very long if it had but we've
obviously taken that very seriously and
and of building that into our
um continuous development plans
so I I thought really that you you'd
want to hear
um about what with what we're doing and
because we're very much of the man that
we haven't arrived requires Improvement
to be good is not where we want to be
we've we've got aspiration to to be
providing good and outstanding
consistent services for for all our
children young people
so there were a number of of clear
um areas that their their Med reference
to in the report for us to take forward
one of which is in respect of the
emergency Duty team which is currently
managed and over the scene through adult
social care
and the fragility of that service I
think it's fair to say had been
recognized prior to the inspection and
we were able to to share with them
um our plans around that service area
and we we had already met with
colleagues from
um another Authority from bury to
um set up a piece of work that they
would do for us in terms of a a peer
review with some options
um for moving that service forward and
we are we're progressing with with that
piece of work so it had already been
kind of set away but then the inspection
has kind of delayed it a little bit but
we we plan to have that and undertaken
in March
um I think the
there's a whole range of work because
the the emergency Duty team social
workers are are predominantly adult
social care or adult mental health
focused so ensuring that they have that
breadth of understanding across
children's that they have opportunities
to shadow
um and to learn from experienced
practitioners in children's
um Emma Brown the director of adult
social care and myself will be meeting
um and putting a clear plan in place
we've already implemented some of those
things and some new templates for the
EDT team to use some training that
they've been aligned to so we're working
closely together and to take that
forward
we have we do have just for your issues
we do have children's on-call managers
that are part of an encore rotor that
are approached for decision making
um out of hours so there is a there is a
strength there as well
just in relation to the complex and
additional needs service we're very
honest in our self-assessment and now
we're set up conversations with the
inspectors that there's still
significant amount of work to do to
stabilize and strengthen that service
and we'd had a quite recent
um new manager and
um changing in the social workers in
that team and which is starting to make
an impact we've presented a report to
the chief executive and Lead member
Assurance meeting
under a report has also gone to the
safeguarding partnership as well in
relation to that service area
um it it's a it's a national issue in
terms of expertise for social work for
children with additional needs number of
authorities are struggling to recruit
permanent and experienced practitioners
for that area of work and we have we
have a detailed action planning place
and we are um overseeing key performance
information on a weekly basis by the
practice manager and head of service
there
we have a date planned for a Leadership
Summit around the children with
additional needs service which is the
8th of March and we'll have a full
partnership Summit later in the year
um and we we acknowledge really that to
meet the needs of these children young
people well that's a partnership
response we we aren't able to do that on
our own and so we bring key leaders
across the system together to
um to consider the way forward in terms
of
um the Strategic or the certain
governance around the children with
additional needs service
in terms of just moving on to children
in care and the support for for care
leavers we are in the midst of reviewing
our current corporate parenting board
strategy action plan in terms of
reference via the corporate parenting
board we've set that piece of work away
and we have um children and young people
who are or have been in Care Now
attending the full meeting of the
corporate parenting board
previously and they were attending at
the beginning to give a presentation on
the issue that we were discussing and
but I think it's giving it a new
emphasis to have them there for the full
meeting
and we know that we we have work to do
in terms of reaching more children and
people that can be involved in some of
that development and that's it's a key
Cornerstone really the participation and
engagement strategy which will be a key
strand in in our corporate parenting
strategy
we we have been reviewing our care lever
offer with our care experience young
people and we are planning with a gender
setting for the next corporate parenting
board and we are planning to have that
on the next agenda for um for a review
and endorsement of that
lots of work we will continue to do in
terms of life story work later life
letters which is is a letter that you
write to children who are might
currently be quite young to explain to
them decisions that have been taken for
them them to read later in life so if
they've had a plan of adoption or a plan
of
um of living permanently away from their
birth parents it's important that their
help to understand that story and so we
are putting in place a strengthening
really of those arrangements and we have
some specialism in the service around
Last Story work that we're going to be
utilizing for that area of work
supervision and management oversight
runs as a as a key theme really across
all of the areas because it's always
been uh Jill and I and my um view that
that first line manager is crucial in
driving improvement and quality of
practice
um we we have progressed in in that area
but there are some bits that are still
just a little bit stuck so we um we are
um strengthening our management
accountability framework in that
oversight of supervision for
practitioners and ensuring that that is
in place for every practitioner there's
some real strength in some parts of the
service around that and the use of um
reflective supervision and group
supervision and but it remains it
remains variable and patchy across the
service really we are continuing to have
a leadership development program for all
of our our managers as well and that
will start to include a coaching and
mentoring offer
so in summary and lots to do
um we view this as part of our
continuous Improvement we haven't
arrived we have great news that we we're
no longer judged to be inadequate and
our Improvement notice is lifted but
there's much more to do really and and
we're committed to that continuous
Improvement we will continue to have
governance Arrangements in place were
working through with the DFE advisor and
our Improvement board what that will
look like and that Ambitions for
children board that aspiration that will
continue across the partnership to build
on those foundations that we've now got
and we just ended with a a couple of
quartz really because we we had we had
lots of positive
um
positive accolades throughout as well as
you might want to have a look at this or
we were just a bit worried about that
but two of two of the the kind of quartz
that really struck with us really about
the care and compassion and passion for
children which was seeping out the walls
at every level and that's that's what
they said at the end of the first week
on site with us and one of them
inspector said he had absolutely seen
some of the best child-centered case
recording that he'd ever seen
excellent
I mean that that just shows you how far
we've come doesn't it you know in in the
space of three or four years so
fantastic so proud of you all yeah I'm
so proud of all of us are there any
questions
councilor Maitland uh I I like to start
it off and start off with those quotes
because I just think they were sorry I
think they're just amazing
um
I'd like to know more about
um a few things
um
the life stories and you probably can't
do that now for me but it might be nice
to see an example of a life story and
these um later life letters I'd like to
know a little bit more about those
um and what we're actually doing for
care leavers in that transition to
Independence
um I think I've asked this before and
that I'd really like to know more about
it
um it's not I know it's not something
you can do right now but
um that would be great
um and I think you've answered my other
questions oh one one more if that's all
right
um the presentation that they're doing
you're doing to the corporate parenting
board will we have that presented to us
as well will we see that on the um
review of care lever off from I mean
that's certainly something that
apologies that's certainly something
that would were happy to to come and
talk to you about if that's going to be
helpful yeah because at the minutes
um and the agendas aren't generally
published are they for um corporate
parenting board but I know I get them
um so yeah I don't see any reason why
not did you watch something chill yeah
one of the things about the life story
work that makes it such a a specialist
saying is that it's not a one-up
activity it's not a single letter if you
think about your own child towards your
own family circumstances you get the
memories as you go through life so you
know when you share memories in terms of
talking to your parents your carers your
grandparents so yes we can show you
examples of parts of that Journey but
actually the critical thing is that for
every child that we're corporate parents
or that we give them the sorts of
experiences and the sorts of memories
that you would have in your own family
so some of the things that the inspector
said about some of the best child
centers recording like storybook starts
from the day that we touch a family from
the day we start to be involved with
them they need to reference in the
keeping in touch that's actually sort of
things that they saw from that child
centered recording would be so helpful
to our children when they came back as
adults and read their records because it
conveyed what we do about them and
convinced the decisions that we made so
there isn't one site that's all
we do tend to be Professor the concrete
fits like you know oh in adoption work
you you're almost required to rent out
at least a late flight so people the
adoption order is agreed and goes
through the course so that's a fairly
concrete thing we're required to write
child performance reports and again
racing them in a way that satisfies the
court process and being able to do
something that children can read as a
record it's been concrete having
photograph albums or or DVDs discs
whatever the modern technology is that
conveys some of those memories their new
concrete
whilst our aspiration is is that it's a
personal approach and it's about doing
what we would do for our own children
and crafting the whole range of things
so it's not just a memory box it's not
just a letter it's not just photographs
it's so that's at any point child will
understand what we did why we did this
and then we equipment to understand how
much parents carers did care about them
and what their circumstances are but we
know we have more to do particularly for
some of our our children that have been
in our care for a long time that the
child Center for recording is is
relatively new which is why it said
please see some of the things that the
inspectors played back to us you'll
remember that they have said previously
about some of the captain are recording
they've focused much less on gas and
record and saw that richness coming
through so if you're still on a journey
and we do have this both training in
terms of place of Life work and live
your map to trauma informed approaches
as well
great thanks Jill councilor Proctor
thank you
hey so first of all
I am so pleased that we have moved
and that that's a relief
um I'm trying to look at both of Youth
but you're both blurred because I've
take my glasses off so I can read
um
and I'm glad your focus hasn't been away
look at what we're doing on but more on
a
this is what we're concerned about and
we're putting plans into place
um I'm really glad to see it it's that
way around because
that there's there's things that that
concern me
that you've managed to alleviate some of
my concerns so thank you so I've got
probably three questions
but I might have more
um
one I'm also I'm really glad that you're
doing something about the out of our
service because it was
so poor at supporting Foster carers
um
that that concerned me greatly so
question one
um
why are we as a local Authority
inconsistent
when we're dealing with 16 and 17 year
olds Who present as homeless
surely we've got a policy and procedure
about how we manage that
I know there's legal issues about
tenancies but it's been got round by
other councils where they become the
tenant for that young person
um my next question
um it raised again that too many
children have experienced changes too
many changes of social workers
so foster carers
um I know of one set of foster carers
who have four different social workers
in less than a year
and
the effort it takes for both the child
and the Foster carers to build a
relationship is
that worries me greatly that
where we can provide consistency we're
not doing and then my last
question
I'll get to it
highlighted things
[Music]
yeah I I thought that we'd invested
massively into supervision
we recruited
many more social workers and Social Work
team leaders
and I'm disappointed and concerned
that
the report said
that the inconsistency in the service
that children receive is made worse by
the variable frequency and quality of
supervision for social workers
because that that's appalling
because social work needs
regular supervision
and that's consistent that's focused on
um what they're doing and without that
supervision we risk social workers
um
not being effective and putting too much
time in the wrong thing or even
go for bed getting things wrong because
they hadn't got that oversight on what
they're doing and that's my biggest
concern thank you I can see Jill's
waiting to come in
tonight so I if I heard it properly
because my quality of my internet's
playing or
um if if I can just start on the 16th
and 17 year olds surely and I guess the
one of the honest answers to that is I
take full responsibility for that
because we are thankful responsibility
for everything that I have to send my
service but it's one of those that I
felt really disappointed in my suffering
and the reason why I say that is that
we've had a peer review carried out by
the Department of Housing leveling up
and communities that have like some
issues we've started to craft the plan
around it we just hadn't quite thought
to the end of what we needed to do when
Austin came in and looked at it I guess
it's one of those things how do you eat
an elephant in small bits and you can't
do everything all at once so
probably the three biggest issues on
that one were that our politics and
procedures were out of date and weren't
necessarily compliant with legislation
so for example haven't taken account of
things like the changes in housing
legislation from the changes in domestic
abuse legislation so if you Google on
our websites we see policies that are
entered out of date we just haven't got
around to update so much
one of the things from the practice
point of view we've been very strong at
dealing with the immediacy of the issue
oh that's a 15 17 year old presented as
homeless let's sort out somewhere for
them to live which we do very well and
we do have a range of provision to do
that but we haven't necessarily dug
underneath the skin of that because you
know in 16 and 17 year olds who's
presenting those painless being kicked
out of their home because they've had a
fallen out your mom and dad or brother
or whatever there's something more going
on and we've been a little bit linear in
our Focus
and the third aspect that was quite
difficult for us was that if somebody is
16 or 17 of presenting as homeless we
should automatically expose voluntary
assessments with housing colleagues be
offending the choice to become
accommodated and to become looked after
and I think in terms of some of the
changes of our redesign of the service
in terms of some of the changes of the
service structure and people who've just
lost sight of that so whilst it's a
really significant issue because
somebody is 16 and 17 and potentially
homelessness is particularly vulnerable
and not listed things for us to overcome
and get breaks
um and we we are
we've got a session it's again slightly
delayed because the bar or
um
our plans were set just as we had some
more new arrivals arriving in the world
to have a session with housing
colleagues with some of our kind of
sector providers with our own staff they
can't how do we take this forward what
do we need to do what we've already
started some training internally with
our own staff I reminded them of the
duty and that we should be asking at
least 16 17 year olds whether they do
want to be cool look that and some of
them will say get lost I don't want a
social worker I'm not going into care I
will draw the state of my mind but it
sort of might be female actually I'm on
somebody to look after me I want to be
cared for I want to know what that looks
like and we've started work on publicity
information and leaflet to share not
just with our own staff but for all your
people so that works going forward in
terms of what that looks like
on the changes of social worker and
we've done some detailed analysis of
what that's looked like in terms of
charting the reduction of what you have
what you don't have to remember but one
of the things that it's useful to
remember is that actually the inspection
that has locked back over the last 12
months minimum sometimes two years so
some of that churn that we've seen as
we've worked through some of the
redesign has been evident on on files
has been a reflection of some of the
things that you've talked about wearing
careers or social workers themselves and
whether I'm relatively new to this case
this is what I can see this is what I've
done and but we all see a real reduction
in tenants of the numbers of changes of
social workers and can't eradicate but
we've had that before and
of stability of worker is increasing
your final point about super
if we create the right environment for
them if we give them manageable Pace
loans if they have access to visible
high quality managers if they're getting
the advice guidance and support that
they need
and they're more likely to say what the
inspection team did tell us is they did
say your workers say they're all
supported your workers say they are
getting supervision it's not that
visible to us either the child's
individual record or in terms of what
they were saying about personal
supervision for a left-hand liquid
because I know she'll want to talk a bit
more about what we have done already in
terms of investing in our managers to
strengthen us
thank you
okay thanks Jill so I mean ABS
absolutely can I go back to the um the
impact on children carers have changed
the social work because we absolutely
recognize that and it was one of the
reasons why we we chose to have that as
a theme at the corporate parenting board
South Foster Career representatives
there had raised that and a number of
meetings and so we had a real focus on
that area and shared the investing in
our people strategy some of the
reduction in the turnover that we we've
had which we're starting to see in the
last six to nine months really
stabilized and then start to reduce we
had interesting conversations around
um
I don't like the term but people are
familiar with the agency workers and
they're entering interim where there are
Workforce they're working with our
children we value them in the same way
um and invest in them in in the same way
and we have some incredible interim
workers who have been with Trafford and
throughout this journey are an offering
offering a fantastic service to our
children but we also have some have had
some interim workers who leave very
quickly and that is um something that
we're working with the region on
developing a pledge across authorities
and trying to reduce that attraction to
some to go somewhere else very quickly
because
that's that's very damaging to children
and carers when it happens very quickly
when when the communication is not right
and that Handover isn't possible and
people the reality is we we all move
jobs people move and progress for all
sorts of reasons but it's how you manage
that that is really important and and
that you know there's a proper Handover
and a proper introduction and that the
child and carers are able to see that
visibly rather than finding out as they
have done previously quite by accident
sometimes and so that's our aspiration
that we manage those transitions well
and obviously our structure is is that
children will move regarding expertise
that's needed across the service one
social worker can't be an expert in
every part of the service and so as we
as we
manage that transition of that child
from one part of the service to another
that we strive to do that really well
and have that really proactive and that
bat on passing
um and and I think we're doing we are
doing better at that but we we meet with
our foster carers Glenn Perryman who was
here at the last meeting and myself a
meeting with our foster carers
um as well as them having their have
your safe forum and
just having that open communication and
just saying you know that isn't where we
want to be this is these are the things
that we're doing to try and move that
forward so I think we're building a
better relationship and and there's more
trust I think between carers and the
service and at this point
um in terms of of supervision that
holding practitioners and I've said that
for slam manager is crucial in in
ensuring quality of practice we have had
some changes of manager we have had some
performance issues that we have
addressed
um and will continue to address but as
Jill said the majority of our
practitioners were openly saying they
like working for Trafford they feel held
they feel supported case loads are
manageable
um and
we we want to build on that because we
want people to have a really good
experience with us and so that they want
to stay because that's better for
children
uh thank you uh could I um obviously
um Council properties mentioned about
the um quality of supervision Etc can I
ask is there adequate time for
reflection for the social workers
um and is is is that allowed on a sort
of a regular basis that's one one
question and have you could you give any
ballpark figure as to the time frame for
the Improvement Journey for the out of
our service obviously there's going to
be a peer review but you know that'll be
because you know you'll that'll be
looked at you know with with an outcomes
and
um the other thing I just wanted to ask
about was the uh
the young people who are in positive
um it's it's mentioned about the
um the hindrance of By changes of
Aftercare workers could you just comment
about that as well thank you I don't
know who's going to come in first on
this I can see Jill's hands up just for
a change
in the time
um just in terms of your first question
of do social workers having time for
reflectional supervision councilman
Blackburn one of the things that we have
to do and have taken forward is we have
working with our practitioners and our
managers they have led on a practice
piece of improvement work to devise also
supervision framework one the critic
opens within my framework with the
separation answer of case supervision
looking at the tasks and the activity
that needs to happen to be helpful with
children from reflective supervision and
the reflective supervision isn't just
about as how we feeling have you got
covered what's going on in your life but
thinking about practice Improvement
thinking about learning thinking about
bits of work that's gone well taking the
balance
um
you know sort of things that you might
think I'm actually on reflection I could
have done that better or these were the
aspects that made that because and we've
linked all of that to our policy
Assurance framework so I'm confident
that people have the time I'm confident
that we've got the framework to do with
one of the things that we have to learn
it's because of the culture change that
the inspectors saw is we we have
definitely got to a stage where people
are much more comfortable thinking about
learning thinking about things from us
and this is good because it could be
improved if I did the the elements of
the program that Pam is talking about
further strength and that are about
enabling people to feel confident to
have those rounded conversations in that
protective space and I guess it it links
lately to councilor Proctor's over your
question when she was saying well
actually invested in role managers you
know this big call to their their being
absolutely it's a brave person isn't it
that knows it's caused their critical
role but says I'm not that confident in
having a reflective conversation I'm
really good at doing the task stuff
we'll say the terms of hugging somebody
with their own learning helping with my
own learnership so actually I've got
a problem
I do think for the great thing so we're
constantly working to get an edible
increase in the right environment
manages to to feel confident around us
and it
the practice of supervision as the next
phase of the inventing of that program
we have some people that are really good
at it we have some people that are new
on their management journey and actually
we want to bring out the best of
everybody in terms of that
thank you
I think the the other thing that I'd say
is the importance of Team you know it's
the manager's responsibility to oversee
direct supervis but the importance of
after that experience practitioners
around you that offer you that guidance
and support and we have some of our some
of our teams have a model of that peer
supervision where if someone is
struggling with with something new or
that they haven't done before they can
bring that and and have a discussion and
get advice about from other people who
might have faced similar situations so
it is absolutely key having that
robustness around that that supervisor
supervisory relationship but then that's
one of the things that Corvette taught
me really is is that absolute importance
in Social Work of being with people
um and I don't know if I if I'd have
qualified that in a corporate year that
I I would still be a practitioner
because I think that was incredibly hard
for managers and social workers alike to
build on relationships virtually but we
are you know we've we've turned a corner
with that and people are with each other
much more than than they are not we've
taken the benefits of hybrid working
forward absolutely but we we're in the
business of relationships with our
children with our families and with each
other and and we're really aspirational
for that to be face to face
um so in terms of the time frames for
the EDT work we hope that that work will
be completed March and April we will
then bring back
um into
um meetings with our new director of
Adult Services and Jill some proposals
for moving forward uh hopefully by the
end of um April beginning of May and if
there's formal consultation needed then
the officer will follow and do HR
processes but I would anticipate at the
summer that we'll be moving that forward
that's great Jill did you want to add
something
[Music]
that the cameras talked about that's in
terms of that peer review and looking at
some of the options appraisals sort of
the improvement work around DDT it's not
waiting for that to happen so some of
the things
already initiated is shadowing with the
front door so that the processes that we
have in the daytime for recording how to
deal with contacts referrals some of
those things are already set Away In
Motion you will have seen in the slide
deck that we've already increased some
of the capacity or based on and an
interim basis until we finalize what the
model looks like in terms of being able
to manage that and then some cheap
trainings and tools supervisions taking
place we've been really quite strong on
the Handover between daytime to make
timing but lesser from night time today
time so again strengthening the
processes there really so it's not as if
the Improvement activity is waiting for
the outcome of the peer review there are
there are concrete things that are
already in place and in being the moment
thanks Jill and are we on today
the final question was was around
um
cost today um that some of our care
leavers who are in in custody and we we
did have some challenges
um during corvid around visiting
um but I think the the changes that
we've had of course the restructuring
care for children and Care leavers we've
had a number of vacancies in our
Aftercare service but we are we're
advertising five vacancies at the moment
so we we're anticipating that as those
poor saw filled the case loads for the
Aftercare workers will reduce so that
they have more time because some
sometimes
um these young adults are at distance
and sometimes there is a reluctance for
them to also to want the Aftercare
worker to visit because they want to use
that visiting time understandably for
family friends
um but we we is an area we definitely
need to push in on and ensure that um
the vulnerable young adult Spa virtue of
their experiences and the traumas that
they've faced and seen this as a
priority group really and raising the
profile of that in the services is
really important for me and also to make
sure that that when when they are then
released from course today
that plan is really clear that that will
enable them to be successfully part of
society rather than starting those
patterns of behavior again so it's
twofold for me it's whilst they're in
custody but it's also that robustness of
the plan for for when they're released
thank you Dad did you want to say
anything I'm sure I knew he won
thank you uh councilor Weston
um so I mean I think Jill and Pamela are
so comprehensively covered the report
and I think the questions that we've had
in the committee this evening have been
um spot on and they're the right
questions to ask and I think this
committee
um all the way through this process
actually has been so
um has been so
um kind of committed to scrutinizing
what's happening in this journey and to
supporting the service with this journey
so
um I would like to put my thanks on
record to to the committee actually for
how you have contributed
um throughout this process which was an
incredibly
um intensive Journey that we've been on
and I hope tonight
um Pamela and Jill and I hope and I can
myself give some Assurance to the
committee really that it um absolutely
this is not the end of the process as
far as we're con concerned
um that pushing forward
um on behalf of children and young
people
um is is absolutely what we are
committed to doing now and I think
there's something
um that I did just want to highlight
actually from
um
from the letter from the minister to the
leader
um in lifting the Improvement notice
which I think absolutely sums up the
journey that we have been on
um which is where the the minister says
how pleased she is
um to see the ofsted have highlighted
the change in culture across the service
to one which focuses on the child and I
think that's absolutely right and I
think you probably
um see reflected this evening in the
openness and the transparency of the
service and the willingness really to
um to hear the voice of of the child
there is no more important and Powerful
voice I think than that of the child we
see that
um in corporate parenting board and I
think they give us the the greatest
Insight
um in telling us you know what it is
that that they need to change and hope
you can see that there is that
willingness to to do that and to
continue
um this journey and again if I may and I
know it might be a bit indulgent of me
but if I could also put my thanks on
record to uh to Jill and Pamela and the
the whole team
um for the commitment that they've had
and that the minister again
um says in her letter that this marks
significant efforts to improve services
for children and families in Trafford
and it's a tribute to the commitment and
hard work of all staff so I would just
like to Echo that thank you chair thanks
Catherine I'm sure we all agree
um absolutely not never imagine
but thank you both so much
um and thank you to your team
I've never seen Jill's loss for words
[Music]
but thank you
so much for all the work you've done and
for joining us this evening
um
until I hope you're soon on the mend
yeah
thank you
thanks Pamela okay I've just got um I've
got no urgent business but I just wanted
um
the work program we've got one one more
meeting left
um in this Municipal year so as always
I've invited the Trafford college
students to come in and give us a
presentation
um
again the voice of the child that is my
favorite meeting of the year I think we
get here from these youngsters these are
our future
um
we've also got a report that was
um deferred on the new arrivals in
Trafford to
um to analyze the impact of the new
arrivals and the council's role in this
I think that's coming from you Pamela
um we've also we did um Ascend task and
finish group
um a year or so ago now perhaps even
more
so um I think Karen's going to bring us
the update on the progress against our
recommendations on that
um and then Jill
um is going to
um give us an in-depth um report on the
savings that we've had to
um Implement on children's placements
and savings for the proposals for the 23
24 year and I will bring we've got a
task and finish group
um going on at the moment for um for
cams which we're doing jointly with
health scrutiny and I think we've got a
meeting next week
um if I remember rightly so I will bring
you an update on that
um so other than that thank you all for
attending
um it's lovely to see you not
taking too long it's been uh quite a
short meeting for us but thank you all
and wish you all the safe journey hey
you thank you
[Music]
no
I watch it on YouTube